Well,
it's good to be back on schedule coffee
on of Tuesday and Vlog 47.
Okay,
so I'm tired of people trying to cash in
on my childhood hogs,
crazy bones,
yoyos pokemon cards.
The TV shows that B,
which just the commercials we sat
through,
the movies that changed our lives.
These things are strong into my heart
with a special tautness sensitive so
that every cheap tug can make me feel
something like,
but not quite genuine emotion.
Maybe you've seen the recently released
ad for Internet explorer called child of
the nineties.
I can't show it for copyright reasons,
but I've put a link in the description
if you want to watch it.
Essentially the ad is a collection of
those fads and items from the childhood
years of my generation,
nothing more certainly,
and I don't know if you could do
anything less.
It's a terrible ad that plays cheaply on
a single emotion,
not unlike those hard commercials for
Spca that show watery eye dogs to the
music of Sarah Mclaughlin.
Excuse me.
Whereas the SPCA,
commercial exploits are natural sympathy
and pity,
poorly for a good cause.
The Internet explorer add exploits our
nostalgia for the loan cause of profit.
Now,
of course,
the exploitation of human emotion for
profit is what makes the entire industry
of advertising despicable and
reprehensible,
but as we are hardly any of us
unconnected to it,
now we speak hypocritically when we
vilify it,
though I've always contended citing my
hypocritical vilification that it can
never be art with a capital,
a advertising edits very best can be so
art full,
so nuanced and spectacular that it
becomes a hotbed of original creative
ideas from which artists of every medium
can steal and use to their advantage at
its worst.
Advertising Cherry picks easy sentiments
and paying them over and over again
until we're all suffering from blunt
force emotional trauma.
We'd been watching ads for a long time.
We know these things.
The difference and nothing makes this
more clear than the child of the
nineties at is that now we.
My generation is the target.
Now we're working in TV like I do.
You hear that term tossed around a lot.
The demo.
How did we do in the demo?
Are we performing well in the demo?
The ratings weren't great,
but it's okay because the demo was good.
Demo is of course short for demographic,
just a particular section of the
population,
but when people say the demo,
they're talking about a very specific
group.
They're talking about people from the
ages of 18 to 49.
These are the golden geese.
The people to whom the gross majority of
advertising and commercial entertainment
is ain't.
Why?
Well,
because we have the money with the
invention of people meters in the early
eighties.
Advertisers could see not only what
people were watching but who was
watching what in the early 19 seventies,
ABC,
the last place network,
unable to pull in a wide swath and
audience sold what had which was younger
viewers and the demo was born.
Total viewing numbers matter less than
performance in the demo.
A good example of this is the simpsons
is a show that routinely ranked
somewhere in the sixties of the most
watched shows,
but the average viewer of the simpsons
is 29 years old and that means that the
simpsons can charge more per commercial
than many of the highest rank show.
It's all predicated on the notion that
young people,
young professionals like me,
have disposable income,
that we're more likely to spend than
older people.
Not only that,
we're more likely to find brands now
that will stick with for a lifetime.
We have the money.
Advertisers want the money and TV shows.
One,
the advertisers.
These are deeply ingrained
relationships,
determining much of what you see and our
soul.
We've passed into the black heart of the
demo now and that means that everything
is up for grabs,
including and especially our memory
knickknacks from the nineties when life
wasn't so terribly depressed by the idea
of rent forever,
when social media didn't exist,
when life was homework and home cooked
meals and everything.
Now,
when these things in their own time
giveaway to the new more complicated and
meaningless things of the future,
it will all be used and every sensitive
heartstring will be pulled and the
generous rosie,
Britta filter of memory will be
exploited so that the perfect time of
then will unfold before our eyes in
glorious escape.
And the only way back there is to
download the newest version of Internet
explorer.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
I wanted to remind you to follow me on
Tumbler.
I love tomorrow.
Now.
It was just a great place to put the
images and things that inspire me all in
one place.
Also,
I am getting better at twitter,
sort of learning how to communicate
interestingly on that site.
Um,
so follow me at the nerd writer.
Both those things are in the description
and I will see you next time.